So, here are some specific examples of
what we can't do today, and part of
speech tagging is not easy to do
one hundred percent correctly.
So in the example: "He turned off the
highway" versus "He turned off the fan"
and the two "off"'s actually have
somewhat different syntactic
categories.
And also it's very difficult to get
complete parsing correct. Again,
the example "A man saw a boy with a
telescope" can actually be very
difficult to parse depending on the
context. Precise deep semantic
analysis is also very hard.
For example, to define the meaning of
"own" precisely is very difficult in a
sentence like "John owns a restaurant".
So the state of the art can be
summarized as follows.
Robust and general NLP tends to be
shallow, while deep understanding does
not scale up.
For this reason, in this course, the
techniques that we cover are,
in general, shallow techniques for
analyzing text data, to mine text data.
And they are generally based on
statistical analysis, so they are
robust,
and general, and,
And they are in the category of shallow
analysis, so such techniques have the
advantage of being able to be applied
to any text data in any natural
language about any topic.
But the downside is that they don't
give us a deeper understanding of text.
For that we have to rely on deeper
natural language analysis techniques.
That typically would require human
effort to annotate a lot of examples of
analysis that we'd like to do, and
then computers can use machine learning
techniques to learn from these training
examples to do the task.
So in practical applications we
generally combine the two kinds of
techniques with the general statistical
and methods as backbone as the basis,
since it can be applied to any text
data and on top of that we're going to
use humans to annotate more data and
to use supervised machine learning to do
some tasks as well as we can,
especially for those important tasks.
So to bring humans
in, into the loop to analyze, fix,
to analyze text data more precisely.
But this course will cover the general
statistical approaches that generally
don't require much human effort.
So they are practically more useful
than some of the deeper analysis
techniques that require a lot of human
effort to annotate text data.
So to summarize this lecture, the main
points to take away are, first NLP
is the foundation for text mining.
So obviously the better we can
understand the text data, the better we
can do text mining.
Computers today are far from being able
to understand the natural language.
Deeper NLP requires
common sense knowledge
and inferences, thus only working for
very limited domains.
Not feasible for large scale text
mining.
Shallow NLP based on statistical
methods can be done in large scale.
And is the main topic of this course
and they are generally applicable to a
lot of applications.
They are in some sense also more useful
techniques.
In practice, we use statistical NLP
as the basis.
And we have humans to help as needed
in various ways.